lundi vous nous donnerez encore d'autres
informations intéressant les
consommateurs mais dans l'immédiat nous
allons rejoindre georges leclercq qui
est au volant d'une curieuse voiture qui
sera peut-être la voiture de demain
georges leclercq
intel et micron un peu spécial
aujourd'hui avec la voiture électronique
qui devient un peu une voiture
informatique
cette voiture va commencer par avoir
quelques fonctions de parole un peu
comme certains micro ordinateurs que je
vous montre
regardez je coupe mon moteur alors que
les lumières sont restés allumés
si je voulais sortir maintenant en
ouvrant la portière les lumières sont
restés allumés
la voiture me le signalent je vais donc
les coupés comme ça mais en fait il ya
beaucoup d'autres fonctions soit dans le
moteur soit dans le tableau de bord
alors on va faire un programme de test
ici qui va nous montrer un peu tout ce
qui se passe et ensuite on fera une
visite dans le coeur du système
le cerveau électronique avec des images
des lois très intéressante
les lumières sont restés allumés
liquide de refroidissement niveau
minimum à vérifier prochainement le
circuit de refroidissement
vas-y
le fram est resté serré asie éclairage
défectueux a vérifié les veilleuses et
la bad de beaux livres numérisés
comprimé
50 messages vont trouver place dans deux
millimètres carrés de ma mémoire
un tas des freins à vérifier
prochainement qui est plaquettes de
freins
alerte le moteur chauffe arrêt moteur
impératif pas de remise en route du
moteur avant diagnostic
heureusement ma discrétion et grands
je suis programmé pour ne parler qu'en
cas d'extrême nécessité
comme j'ai cumulant mémoire quantité
d'informations je suis prêt à répondre à
toutes les questions
les fonctions sous contrôle ne présente
pas de défaut
merci
voilà merci
là
qui va pas eloignez-vous où jouent des
clans cela
et oui je saurai demain obéir fidèlement
à la seule loi de mme et m moteur
anti brouillard
droite gauche clignoteurs
détresse aujourd'hui dans les voitures
laboratoire je sais déjà en connaître la
parole klaxons
essuie glaces le conducteur m'apprend
d'abord les mois correspondants au
déclenchement d'un organe de la voiture
et je range chaque mot en mémoire de
jiwa
terminé
quand sur la route l'ingénieur prononce
un démo radio aussitôt je reconnais sa
forme aussi fidèlement que les reconnaît
sa serrure france inter
santé
mon sens
essuie glaces
grâce à la commande vocale arrête le
regard des conducteurs pourra mieux se
concentrer sur la route appel
a tel appel appel appel appel appel
radar anti collision radar en action
c'est le rêve n'est ce pas et bien
aujourd'hui tout ceci est possible
d'informatique est prête
les circuits électroniques résiste aux
chocs de la route
ce n'est plus qu'une question de prix et
deux dernières mises au point
tout ce que vous avez vu dans ce film va
bientôt être installée sur les voitures
de série dont peut-être bientôt la vôtre
etonnant non